they're very willing and able to target
journalists and activists and people
there either critical of the state or
corporations and that's really what
Barrett was looking into is this
collusion between the government and the
private intelligence industry oh hi I'm
Zak why smaller for reason TV i'm here
with kevin gallagher director of free
barrett Brown a legal defense fund for
Barrett Brown and online activist and
journalist who was imprisoned in
September 2012 for posting a link to
leaks material among other things Kevin
thank you very much for joining us thank
you for having me Barrett Brown was one
of the first if not the first person to
actually be imprisoned for posting a
link on a website could you explain the
backstory on that back in December 2011
some people associate with anonymous had
hacked into stratfor strategic global
intelligence which is a firm in Texas
that collects intelligence from all
around the world they had released their
emails and also their customer database
now what Barrett Brown did is he was in
a chat room at the time and you know
when the data came out and the hackers
put it online he merely posted a link to
it to to point it out to his his
researchers that he was working with to
say Oh check this out see let's see
what's in here you know who who is a
client of Stratford basically and the
government later after having arrested
him indicted him for sharing a link and
for that crime he was facing up to 45
years in prison and he again to clarify
he was not the person who actually
perpetrated the hack they arrested
someone in connection with that and I
believe he faced about 10 years so what
explains that disparity I think that
just shows is politically motivated
prosecution and persecution really and
it ties into the the wider theme that's
happening right now which is the US
government going after journalists and
whistle
lowers with with whatever they can do
they'll just make up charges so Barrett
Brown was really over charged and the
charges were bogus so if you're saying
that it's a political crime then we need
to get a little bit more into the
details of what exactly the Stratfor
leaked reveal so Stratford is a private
security firm has lots of government
contracts around the world what exactly
was in that information that was of
interest to Barrett Brown a number of
newsworthy things came out of the
Stratford emails and still to this day
journalists are finding things in there
every day because they're posted on
wikileaks org one of the things was
coca-cola had hired them to look at PETA
and servile PETA also Bhopal India
activists and they're also monitoring
the Occupy Wall Street protests what
we've learned about private intelligence
firms in large part because of the leaks
like Stratfor and HP Gary shows that
they're very willing and able to target
journalists and activists and people
that are either critical of the state or
corporations and that's really what
Barrett was looking into is this
collusion between the government and the
private intelligence industry so the FBI
raided Barrett's home and seized a
number of his laptops and hard drives
and in the process they actually charged
his mother with a crime of obstruction
of justice for allegedly hiding one of
his laptops and this seems to have
really kind of sent him over the edge he
posted a very angry rambling video on
YouTube which is still up there
supposedly threatening an FBI agent how
did this change the case well it gave
them a pretext to arrest him what he was
saying that a video was basically you
know it's been six months since you guys
the FBI raided me and you haven't filed
any charges what's happening here like
I'm a journalist why can't I get my
laptop's back he had been working on a
book and he had all this valuable
material on those computers which then
put him at a loss because it's in still
in possession of the FBI Barrett's work
turned into something called Project
p.m. could you tell me a little bit
about what that was
what its goals were project p.m. is like
a crowdsourced think tank where he's
basically solicited soliciting
volunteers from the internet to go
through the emails that were hacked and
leaked out of HP gary and stratford to
find things of significance and
journalistic revelations within them
originally when project p.m. was formed
Barrett's goal was to kind of reform the
media because he believed that people
who did not deserve to have an influence
within the media had undue influence and
that um he was writing a book about you
know criticizing colonists and pundits
and stuff like that it evolved into what
it became which is a distributed think
tank to investigate the private
intelligence industry stratfor was a
privately owned company so do people
have a right to their data and shouldn't
there be some sort of prosecution for
these kind of leaks I think well you can
be shown that the leaks are in the
public interest in so far as as they
reveal these private entities actually
targeting the public I think the
government outsources to private
intelligence firms in order to avoid the
types of accountability that they could
be subject to through the Congress and
also the capabilities that they have
within the private sector are years
beyond what what we can even imagine so
I think as far as privacy is concerned
it's we should be very concerned about
it these leaks and the entire Barrett
Brown saga happened before any of the
Snowden leaks that really grabbed the
public attention occur do you see some
sort of through line from the work that
Barrett was doing to the eventual Edward
Snowden leaks i do i think the Snowden
leaks have indicated the things that
bear was talking about for years and it
was like no one was listening and people
called him paranoid but actually he was
right about everything and also Booz
Allen Hamilton which was Snowden's uh
his last employer before before he left
um the NSA was affirmed that Barrett was
actually investigating and looking into
with project p.m. you've been
corresponding with him as he's been
sitting in prison for the past 19 months
he's finally reaching some sort of plead
out deal how what's his mindset at this
point I get the sense that he's very
laid back in and optimistic about
everything he's looking forward to
getting out and he has a very good
chance of getting out soon which you
know before he made this plea agreement
that was all up in the air it was all
very uncertain he had over a hundred
years hanging over his head so I think
he's just looking forward to continuing
his life and you know picking up his
journalism where he left off what do we
know about the details of the plea deal
if anything what is he what's been
dropped and what is he still being
charged with or what might still be on
the table we don't know the exact
details but we presume that it's
actually very favorable and generous to
him he's still charged with obstruction
of justice and a new canoe count which
is accessory after the fact to an
unauthorized access of protected
computer which is a strange charge
because it's essentially him protecting
Jeremy Hammond the hacker who acted to
Stratfor and the prosecutors are saying
that he created confusion over Jeremy
heavens identity and at least one charge
related to the the videos which he made
in speaking out against the FBI agent
when it comes to computer related crimes
that the penalties just seemed out of
proportion to anything else we saw the
same thing with Aaron Schwartz he was
facing decades for basically releasing
information to an academic database what
is wrong with the computer laws in this
country I think there's like a hacker
hysteria and the fact that judges to do
not understand technical issues and
prosecutors play up on that to say that
you know a hacker could like like they
said during the kevin Mitnick trial in
the 90s he could he could blow into a
pay phone and launch nuclear missiles
anyone interested in learning more about
this case or lending their support where
should they turn they should go to free
Barrett Brown to work and also we're on
Twitter as free Barrett underscore
definitely urged people to donate to the
legal defense fund so we can cover his
his legal costs Kevin Gallagher thank
you very much for talking to us Thanks
sec for reason TV I'm Zach why similar